and me getting my Oscar and I want to  thank the best we're gonna have you hold  up this picture of Leonardo DiCaprio and  put it next to your face and I'm gonna  swap your faces okay oh I feel so good  obviously you know Leo DiCaprio very  well yes you want to swap faces hold  this for a sec sure this is kind of  unholy my acceptance speech I probably  thank all Native Americans including  that one hand someone named Forrest good  luck so there's a filter that just came  out like swap your feeds filter you're  about to do like Julia I really want to  fight the best could see was a really  big part in my supposed to be talking  are you filming  Lea what do you think your chances  tonight hundred percent they're easy  go to change.org /er a and get women  equal rights in america have you guys  done this space walk  thanks to everybody he thanks the  director affects a hawk  yeah the Haggadah movie the revenant is  a great guy